good afternoon
speaking on behalf
of 11 families who I represented in this
inquiry
today's report confirms everything we
feared about the catastrophic failings
of the emergency services on the night
of the Manchester Arena bombing
so many failures happened on that night
it is impossible to list them all here
this damning report sets out in
meticulous detail how the emergency
service response lacked preparedness
planning coordination communication
resources and equipment
almost everything that could go wrong
did go wrong it is totally unacceptable
that members of the public were left
seriously injured and dying in this way
for what must have seemed like an
eternity
it is clear that the so-called golden
hour after the attack was utterly
squandered by the catastrophic response
of the emergency services
as the John says the Emergency Services
simply failed to get a grip
what makes this even worse is that so
many of the lessons of today's report
could and should have been learned after
the seven seven bombings in 2005. 12
years after 7-7 the same things went
wrong again at Manchester Arena
the complete and utter failure of the
government and the emergency services to
learn those lessons and Implement them
on a national level is wholly
unacceptable this must never happen
again
as Sir John powerfully States in his
report some of our clients line
seriously injured in the city room could
hear the sirens outside and kept
expecting help to come but no one came
to help them
we agree with Sir John that there needs
to be greater tolerance of risk across
the Emergency Services
so John has set out over 25 pages of
detailed recommendations the sheer scale
of recommendation shows that the system
is truly broken and needs a complete
overhaul
every single emergency service needs to
admit its mistakes honestly and commit
without defensiveness or hesitation to
implement Sir John's recommendations
without delay it must happen and happen
right away our loved ones who died in
this atrocity deserve nothing less thank
you
I now have a statement
um on behalf of John Atkinson's family
which they've asked me to read today
John was our son brother uncle and
friend
everyone who knew him loved being around
him he always put others first
as today's report says his working life
was spent helping those in care and his
kindness and generosity were evident for
all to see
he lit up our lives and there is less
laughter in the world without him
since his passing our lives have been
shattered
today the inquiry has answered our
questions about John's death
it is now clear Beyond any doubt that on
the night of the bombing John was
totally failed at every stage both by
the private medical providers at the
arena
etuk and the Emergency Services it is
crystal clear that due to those failings
John died from injuries that he could
and should have survived
as the report says timely medical
treatment to stop or slow John's
catastrophic bleeding and get him to
hospital would have saved him
during this crucial time Ronald Blake
acted heroically to try to save John we
want to say thank you again to Ronald
Blake for all he did that night however
the medical tourniques John needed were
not made available and the paramedics
who could have saved him should have
been at the scene much sooner as the
report says responsibility for these
failures lies squarely with etuk SMG who
commissioned etuk to provide medical
services at the arena and Northwest
Ambulance Service finally had greater
Manchester fire and rescue service
arrived at the scene earlier as they
should have done they could have used
their stretches to get John out of the
city room much sooner and with much less
pain
even after John was moved from the city
room to the casualty clearing station
further delays meant that he was not
prioritized for evacuation to hospital
he was left dying without his dignity on
the floor when it should have been
obvious to Medics that he needed to get
straight to hospital
as we know from Witnesses John kept
asking if he was going to die
John must have known that he was dying
and the pain that causes us to say that
is too great to put into words this
should simply never have been allowed to
happen
the apology from Northwest Ambulance
Service means nothing unless they act
rapidly on this report to ensure that no
family ever has to go through this
horrific experience again
we welcome sir John's promise to monitor
the implementation of his
recommendations we will be watching to
see what happens now
we thank the chair for his meticulous
and fearless report John will always be
in our thoughts and in our hearts thank
you
thank you
good afternoon everybody can I just
please start by thanking
um Sir John for the amazing
role he played in as a chair I also want
to thank our Barrister John Cooper for
his sometimes ferocious challenges
throughout the inquiry and also our
fantastic legal team who are still
guiding us through this process
so my statement I want to make it clear
that this is a statement as Martin's mum
Martin head's mom who lost his life at
the Manchester Arena on that grateful
night I don't speak on behalf of anyone
else other than myself I I want to make
that really clear
today we've learned about the failings
of the Emergency Services there's no
denying that some of these failings led
to loss of life I'm not here to play the
blame game what we learned today will
not bring Martin or anyone else back for
that matter what is important from this
day forward is to learn from these
mistakes so that they don't happen to
anyone else in the future we must ensure
that the Emergency Services introduce
measures befitting of today's
recommendations to ensure that more
lives are saved should another such
attack happen again in the future
including some of the
recommendations in the report I.E better
communication between all services
establishing a common use of language so
that everybody understands the
terminology in the same way
joint training exercises on a regular
basis
action cards in all services and
training on how to use them correctly
understand each other's capabilities
between the services expertise
specialist equipment available and
resources but also limitations
better communication between senior
command structure across all services
operational discretion rather than just
sticking blind little rules
the use of Technology what was mentioned
today was an up for key contact as a
possibility
regular reviews of operational
procedures across all services and of
course regular updates trauma kits
widely available at publicly accessible
locations
trauma training for police officers
rather than just first aid training
licensed security people this is
something the Sia need to consider
young people as part of the national
curriculum so John wants this introduced
in schools which I think is the right
thing and just imagine if every school
child would learn that in another decade
every adult who you know would have
those skills and the general public of
course you know in the arena there were
lots of people from the general public
had they had the skills they would have
maybe been able to help better so and
also finally another point that came out
was learning from what other countries
are doing so as many of you know I have
been also complaining about Martin's law
uh what I ask is the government finally
brings forward the legislation required
to ensure the country's safety despite
the apparent government's support that I
have
been promised and I keep being promised
this much needed law appears to be
constantly delayed
um I had Martin's law been in place that
night we now know that precious life
would have been saved we can't turn the
clock back but for every passing day
that today's recommendations and
Martin's law are not in place is yet
another day where all of our safety is
at risk today is not a day for finger
pointing but a day for Learning and
moving forward with measures to keep us
safe UK politics May well be in turmoil
but there's absolutely no excuse for
delaying or weakening legislation that
could save thousands of lives this must
be absolutely a priority the security of
all citizens is at risk and it's up it
is about time that the people came first
now one last thing I would like to add
is that Sir John made a comment about
Martin's law earlier the protect duty to
be hurried along for larger venue
that is really important but a lot of
large venues already know what to do and
it will be clearer once the legislation
is being issued and they know what to do
but the legislation is crucially
crucially important for smaller venues
as well who actually often don't know
what to do and the training of Staff
guidelines of what to do in a terrorist
attack that is crucially important more
so for smaller venues thank you very
much
um I'm Martin's stepfather
and um
also I'm a doctor a GP I've been working
in the NHS 30 years and listening to the
evidence has hurt me the medical
failings so I'd like to just say these
few words
I've sat and I've listened
and now we have the evidence
it's absolutely disgraceful that large
corporate companies can make money by
cutting back on basic first aid measures
which have been proven to save lives
I call on the government and the
Department of Health and Social care to
follow Sir John's recommendations
to collaborate with the Care Quality
commission and to weed out this shameful
practice
thank you